yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is not a blitz video but something
else yeah I'm going to show you an easy
to learn way to play against the London
system the ever-popular
Queen pawn opening with default Bishop
f4 and this is not a completely
Universal system that you can play with
every move water and whatever wieder
does you can do the same thing but you
can address one particular move order
that is very popular with our thing and
easy to learn system that gives black
fair chances I'm going to present you
this system by going through two of mine
over the board classical time control
games that are played in recent month
the first game and the two games they
are not that long so it's not going to
be a super long video let's look at the
the first game that was played in an
open tournament that I played in early
September 2018 in Ottenberg in Bavaria
it's a nice little tournament five
rounds a weekend tournament
I've played there for the second time
and they will play them again this year
this game was played in the final round
I had two black pieces against Martin
garnish my opponent is rated I think
roughly 2150 something like that I don't
have it I don't have that written down
at the time of the tournament but
something like that I needed to win the
game it was the final round and I didn't
have such a good event so I was looking
for a quick way I needed to prepare by
what I saw trying to say I'm with a
little time on my hand and I saw that my
opponent basically every time plays d4
Bishop f4 so I played this Bishop f4 and
then I went d5 which makes this a valid
system from to move orders deep
Knight f6 Bishop f4 d5 or d4 d5 Bishop
f4 nine f6 the second game that I'm
going to show you I actually played e5
on the first move and then Knight f6 now
white played III and the system that I'm
suggested today suggesting to play is
only possible against this particular
move order it is a different kind of
animal if white plays Knight f3 that is
simply a different a different move
water that does not allow this
particular idea that I'm going to show
the ideas I mean okay you have other
options here like c5 in particular is
mostly played but what is the idea
against this
my suggestion is play Bishop g4 this
move I only found briefly here just very
briefly before the game like 20 minutes
before and I have found some games in
the database by some good players and I
was surprised that this move is
virtually unknown but actually quite
good so what's the point of course we
are checking the Queen and white needs
to react directly cannot do whatever he
has to do something and this limits the
choice is quite nicely which is I think
quite good if you wonder some sort of a
surprise weapon or something that it's
not going to be a huge chunk of theory
to learn it's not bad if they don't have
that many options so um the critical
move in a way should be f3 yeah trying
to make use of this Bishop move that
moves basically into thin a eyes stop
pinning anything and there 3 is the move
that was played in both of the games
that I'm going to show the alternatives
in a way less critical but maybe even
like objectively better we will see so
what else is there white could play
Bishop e2 that is a normal-looking move
of course but here after Bishop takes 2
I think black is already
can be quite happy if wide recaptures
with the Queen and we have more than one
decent option the only question that we
have to answer for ourselves is do we
want to play very conservatively like
with c6 and that e-cigs and so on or can
we do even more I think even if six is a
decent move because the check doesn't
really hurt us all that much this is
something that is interesting to analyze
and because it can play this and get
this back you have a fair amount of
compensation here even this is a
possibility but the very simple move c6
is going to be perfectly fine as well if
you build up with black this kind of
triangle with e6 to come if you build
this up with black and you have the
bishop traded on c8
yeah you're usually okay it's just not a
position where White has many active
things available so we should be two
fields uncritical Knight f3 it's
basically a self pin and it does not
feel very dangerous either here black
again has a choice between c6 based
setups or playing a six I think there is
really no need for c6 here I would go
with six and I don't really see a huge
problem here for black the next move can
be Bishop e6 and we have I think already
comfortably equalized in some way f3 is
the only way to tackle Bishop g4 with
ambition so while played f3 it is the
most interesting move and you have to
see when okay I was the huge favorite in
this game but my opponent also in order
to win some sort of prize money you
should probably try to win and they're
free it is the most ambitious move so
black simply drops back to the 7 and
this is not the most obvious square this
heaven is very rarely a good square for
Bishop but in this particular case
there's simply no other square you don't
want to go all the way back to see
that's a little bit too much and the
other squares don't look good something
like this is going to be answered by g4
probably we will see that after Bishop
d7 the move g4 is in fact quite
interesting I am not sure if it is a
good move objectively speaking but it is
something that would definitely test our
course a little bit more than small gasp
slower slow approaches g4 gains a lot of
space on the kingside and it prevents
Knight h5 which can be an annoying move
here black will probably play me six and
c5 and initiate a bit of counter plane
against the center one interesting point
that is yeah quite often seen in many
lines here said after c5 and Queen to b6
there is sometimes Bishop to b5 which
all of a sudden make sense of the
slightly awkward bishop position and a
position like that yeah definitely is
going to be very sharp like airplane c5
and so on and white has this big
expansion on the kingside but this is
also weakening I think if you want to
get an interesting position with black
against and London this is a good bet so
I'm happy with this position it is
difficult to really yeah make a clear
verdict about the objective evaluation
engines tend to favor black iam I guess
the long-term weaknesses here something
that the engine does not like I mean you
can really ask yourself where's the king
going to go when the white king and it's
not so easy to Castle queenside
if black is coming with c5 and so on
this is actually quite quick so g4 is
ambitious the move C form is also
interesting but I don't think all that
grade because black has an immediate
counter play with c5 if the center opens
up this weird configuration here will be
a problem this is very evident if we
look at the movie 5 which is ok it's
very bad but here we see the problem
yeah if there if the pawn would be so
back on f2 white ok
it has bishop g3 at least and here you
don't have a good move at all and you
cannot really move this anywhere and
everything is under big pressure ok see
the CTX d5 is a very silly move but in
general I think I'm quite happy here if
the center opens up then ff3 III is a
problem for example if one after taking
a 6 and in line like this black is
definitely happy yeah I'm getting this
back and then I'm playing a position
where the move f3 is completely useless
it just gives white some weaknesses and
there is no real benefit an interesting
approach I think on move 5 is Knight c3
trying to be quick with the queenside
castling after e6 like again intense e5
white could go a form which leads to
sharply after taking and Bishop before
there is quite a bit of pressure on
white center and the bishop in some
cases can go to c6 again making some
sense of this somewhat weird really
plays piece this is all pretty much
uncharted waters so it's um it's
interesting also to analyze I don't want
to analyze every single line here this
is very difficult because there's
there's not much games that you can rely
on in term I mean just exploring it a
little bit for yourself
is is a good thing to do let's look at
some more motifs that will also help
quite a bit
92 was played in in my game nearby and
my garnish
I went c5 and he played C 3s usually
happens in the London and they play C 3
you have to ever always check what
happens if white does capture this is an
important thing to check if
you just lose the pawn it's no good
however an important point is after 96
that they were simply not a knight on a
three with a knight on f3 instead then
there would be control over in five but
White has no control and I will play the
e pawn possibly even to e5 and then take
on c5 with a nice position so it's
understandable that y23
I played Knight to c6 and now I played
Bishop to d3 that makes them quite some
sense it's does the square to go to
where would you develop the bishop to
otherwise you can make an argument in
favor of g4 this is what the engine is
also pointing out and this is a very
similar position to one to one that we
saw before where g4 s played on mu5
already and it's interesting to consider
how black should play you can definitely
play with a six but an idea that I like
is g6 the idea would be on very
long-term to play Bishop g7 and prepare
in five if you can play e5 would be
excellent of course this position here
is very unclear why can push h4 for
example and black board probably go age
six not not a necessity but it's kind of
normal to react like that and that is
just very complicated yeah
tough tough to evaluate but I think it's
a good position against many London
system players because it is someone
unusual simply yeah oftentimes players
who employ the London they have their
deform c3 III setup worked out and this
is not a conventional position the
slight issue with Bishop d3 Vaughn what
bit was played by my opponent is the
idea to play Knight h5 that's what I did
note only possible because tonight is
now save on age five points on f3 okay
he wants to keep the bishop goes to g5
at age six bishop back and here there
are a couple of options and it is
possible that I did not play in the best
possible way absolutely possible
I played Queen to b6 that's not a bad
move but there are other interesting
choices here as well one is to take on
d4
the idea is that after the recapture and
it's both um recaptures are made with
the same idea is to play this f4 all of
a sudden is available bishop f1 has to
be played and now very powerful g5 + e5
what you should g35 it's the same idea
this is a very aggressive approach and
probably a very good one I think that
after C takes d4 white should probably
take with the C pawn but that is also
not something that is very scary Black
has g5 that can lead to very interesting
complications or again Queen to b6 g5 is
interesting in particular because of the
reply Bishop F to e5 and now F form this
leads to very complicated play now black
could play a form with an interesting
position or a very funny line Knight
takes a form cron takes and E for now if
Y preserves the Bishop which probably
would happen you can get this and all of
a sudden we have a position where black
has two pawns form a piece but a very
strong imposing pawn sent on fyd form
it's very complicated
position so taking on the phone ring the
six was a decent alternative but my
movement moves not bad just like she
takes was a very good way of playing as
well Queen b6 is important to see that
now the move Queen to b3 is not that
great actually I can take
Knight takes obviously failed so the
point is to take and now taking on d4 is
very annoying for white something like
this is not very much fun and here again
Knight f4
it's going to be an annoyance yeah
something like that
it's not much fun again like it's very
active and yeah and quite quite in good
shape Queen b3 it's not a move that
scared me all that much the move that is
probably most interesting here is right
taking that leads to quite um quite
sharp complications I can simply take on
c5 of course if I want and then Bishop
f2 and all of a sudden before becomes an
option this is definitely okay for black
I can just move the Queen away let's say
here and I'm okay the more interesting
way is to check on b2 and basically
claim that that is some the destruction
of White's pawn structure and therefore
should be heavily considered I think
that is probably what I would have done
I cannot tell for absolutely sure
because it's been a while yeah yeah 92
probably and now Queen a3 trying to take
this White has a bit of development
though that something that you
absolutely need to admit here with black
and that means you have to be a little
bit cautious there with many Queen walls
that would have been very unclear he
played 92 basically offering the b2
phone at this moment however taking it
it's not yes so advisable I played a5 we
can we can check briefly what would have
happened if I would have taken the pawn
for example after c4
Bishop C - Queen B - there is Ruby 1
and something like this this is very
similar to the game actually here
however white has some play with the
idea to play me for like for example I
go is six and he goes inform this is not
easy it's not easy to play we will see
the difference to the game where white
had no counter play I decided not to
take anything but just play e5 this is
part of of the agenda anyway I grabbed
the center you know it's better more
active than grabbing a pawn so he played
Bishop f2 and now I'm probably not
playing in the best possible way it
seems best through to simply complete
development with the means like Bishop
e2 this is not the only move can also
play Queen c7 or something but just like
keep the tension I made a calculation
mistake him I played it takes d4 that is
not yet a mistake yeah in some way it is
because after this I played this with
the intention to play C form and this is
not not that great actually I think it
would have been a lot better as
mentioned to keep the tension in this
position
the issue was after c4 then I only
considered the bishop means that he
actually played I thought I would be in
very good shape here and I was in the
game because he played this yam and then
I grabbed on b2 and had a quite quite
large advantage the problem was he was
able to take on c4 and this is a move
that I did not evaluate correcting it is
not that I'm worse but I am NOT better
any more takes I basically have to take
him and then d5 and all of a sudden this
is getting active now after Queen B to D
takes c6
you can also analyze rupee 1 there are
some more complications there but he
will
to take this back and you probably get
this position and this is not clear at
all I mean I've got the bishop pair but
White's development is good and I don't
h5 is very offside and move like 96 for
example there's probably giving white an
equal game very much likely at least and
I think if I'm not going for this and
rather here keep the tension I should be
a little bit better
he played Bishop c2 though and this is
now a problem I can just grab this and I
did yeah would be one Queen eight two we
have to take everything here and now
white still can put up a good fight if
he would have played Luke a1 I'm not
convinced that this is enough material
compensation but it's better than Luke
takes b7 he took on b7 and this is what
the engine suggests and now the move
Knight have won this is a move they're
probably a human player wouldn't even
consider but the engine points out that
with 93 and if this night should move
which is quite likely back to f6 then
Knight f4 that there is some pressure
against e5 this is not super clear yeah
if you return to be 693 for example yeah
and then if you play Knight f6 Bishop
Age form and I kind of it's not also all
that clear yeah I can play 97 but that
is also not the most natural probably
black is fine the engine things makes
better but this is compared to the game
probably the better chance it's two
points in the game if it was just one
point down but he had absolutely no play
like he took here I went back to a6
Queen B 1 and now Bishop d6 and the
problem is I'm just threatening 98 like
happened here and now the rook has to go
back there is just nothing active
possible
I was actually expecting to maybe give
the exchange but this is also ultimately
not leading to anything he went to be to
and now I can simply castle and I'm a
pawn up it's a pond outside passer and
which is almost more important all these
pieces are absolutely bad they don't
attack anything and there's no counter
play
he played Bishop f5 Queen c8 for trades
and here we are already in a technical
phase down
a5 the point is too strong getting this
back into play and now I'm not difficult
but in nice long short Bishop before
leaves this rook stranded and if he
moves it to b6 and I take on c3 he took
on before and yeah I don't have to say
much about this it ended with this with
this move giving her the Queen to get it
back with interest so um we see that
this line irritated my opponent quite a
bit and this is not the only game that I
had with the line as many as there is a
second game I'm going to switch to that
and we have the same position after four
moves as mentioned it happened why a d4
d5 this time so my opponent is Tomas
steel it's a freedom master he's rated
two thousand two hundred seventy or
eighty give or take a couple of points
and he also had not really ever looked
at Bishop g4 as he told me he said he
was aware of the move but had no real
preparation or anything and he didn't
know the first game that was played in a
small tournament that it's not in a Dana
place okay he played Bishop g3 in this
particular position he was concerned
about the new tonight age 5 and
therefore retreated yeah there's some
some logic to that definitely so I went
to c5 again he went c3 can I played
knight c6 basically in the same way as I
played in the game against Martin
garnish came before me and it's
interesting that the engine stock fish
already recommends more drastic measures
h5 in particular I briefly thought about
this I have to say that I'm just too
much of a classical player Joe to come
up with this it is not a bad idea if you
look at this it makes perfect sense
h4 is some kind of a threat pushing the
bishop back gaining space it's
definitely a move it's just very
aggressive and I'm more let's develop
pieces the kind of person but I'm sorry
but it was a good a good option in each
fight also g6 immediately was a good
move and the reason why you can maybe
question knight c6 lightly is that now
with DC 5 white could have taken this
pawn I don't think it is that great but
it's something that you don't
necessarily want to play sometimes there
because you're not going to get it back
easily yeah I was in the game I was
basically thinking okay he's not going
to do that with this kind of weird
formation with the e3 point
weak but it is not completely clear for
example after a six before a5 the engine
suggests Queen d2 which is now possible
in contrast to other cases of those pawn
grabs because 94 is prevented the engine
actually gives black an advantage here
and I do and I don't understand why I
mean White's
whole piece development coordination is
kind of off and it is just a pawn yeah
it's not the end of the world so this is
a bit smoky it's difficult to play
position I wanted to point out that an
idea that I also had during the game
it's the move b6 and this possess
because after taking Queen b6 black is
definitely enjoying very nice
compensation you look at this and this
if if I've ready just be five and you
are definitely fine the problem what the
test let's say is Bishop a6 threatening
to win the exchange and in fact this is
not a chair terrible line this exchange
leg here black has some compensation for
the exchange
the engine is giving why just a very
minuscule advantage and it's a full
exchange here the Bishop Pam it will be
very nice and the play on the dark
squares will be very nice note that this
would be almost for sure incorrect if
the sorry if the point is back on f2 and
there is no weakness here and I won't
dog square complex so some interesting
complications and move that is also
playable after the capture is of course
eighty-five simply stopping before I
wasn't really sure what to do actually
it was kind of a was a bit of a semi
bluff and I don't I simply thought okay
he will not take and if he does I have
chances I definitely have some but I
didn't have a clear idea what to do he
played ninety two and here there are a
couple of interesting options I
reasonably quickly played g6 because I
was influenced by some novella some
analysis that I did on something
entirely different where I'm after the F
pawn move was provoked the fianchetto
was strong because you prepare a five
and sometimes you can go to age six and
it's it's okay you can play g6 but other
moves were good as well Queen b6 for
example also made quite a bit of sense
one idea worth noting is this one which
again shows that III is vulnerable so
there were a couple of options g6 is not
bad though
an interesting idea now for white would
have been again to take that gains a bit
more interest here because I have played
g6 and the natural recapture on c5 is a
bit less attractive I cannot ever play
something like Bishop h6 and this leaves
two pretty crazy complication or
something like this is given by a stock
fish and yeah I don't dare any
assessment issues wild he played Bishop
d3 though and now I played Knight to h5
you can argue that maybe taking on d4
first was better it's definitely
something that I should have considered
a bit more I played this a little bit
too quickly
after the capture the idea is that here
9 h5 or Bishop h6 is a little bit less
of counter play for white you see there
was one option in the game where that I
will show the option was that yeah white
could play f4 in this position again
this is not super terrible or so for me
I played Knight h5 immediately but that
was maybe better than the game stuff to
say what I should play now probably just
Queen to b6 the thing is that this is
not all that clear yes this is a bit
weak but it's still a fairly sturdy
structure
I think f4 was something that he should
have considered in this position another
move that was possible was to take on c5
but then I take and play his six the
reason why I'm showing this line is
mostly because of an important motif if
he tries to do this
it is simply possible to play b6 and
make a full gambit out of this in such a
position yet black has really excellent
compensation you have to pay off bishops
this Bishop will be very strong here and
there are tons of weaknesses on dark
squares and we have a bishop to exploit
that just wanted to show this points
provides a fairly standard way of
sacrificing a pawn in the game after
night age five he played 92 and after
that I was reasonably sure that I should
have a fairly large advantage I took and
play d5 again it was possible and maybe
more precise to take on d4 first after
e5 he now missed an opportunity not
something where he's better anything but
I think putting up a better fight
probably best us to take on c5 here and
play before trying to make some sort of
statement in the center and trying to
exploit the fact that the development
what development is not not that bad
here I expected this to happen and I
wasn't entirely sure what to do I saw
that this is probably a little bit
better for black when we preserve the
bishop and on a very good day we managed
f5 but things are not all that clear I
can play Queen b3 or Bishop c4 here for
example or after afford to play d4
I think I would have rather taken only
four because I wanted to open the
position for the bishops but this is not
a bad choice either probably something
like that will happen and here black is
also I guess quite happy but it was
better I think than the game after pawn
takes e5 Knight takes this position
makes a really bad impression at the e3
pawn is on a half-open foul now
interestingly here I took a bit of time
until I played Queen to b6 Queen to b6
fairly it's a typical candidate move yet
looking at this looking at this only
three the thing is the move Bishop g7
looks more natural during the game
however I was unsure how to handle
Knight takes Knight to b3 now the Queen
is attacking of the pawn and the knight
is a
the pond and I'm not really able to save
both the engine eleven points out that I
can simply play like that and have a
great position this is once you see it
afterwards fairly obvious yeah you have
Queen to e7 coming
you have ninety four it's it's pretty
bad during the game name I didn't want
to sacrifice anything and I didn't see
this this line or that clearly so I went
Queen to b6 he played nine f4 which is
the good move Bishop c6 and now I think
the final opportunity to keep the game
going was a form that was that was the
move that I expected the pointer said
now if I take Knight takes this is
actually not too bad there is this and
this now in the position so I should not
take this but rather Castle queenside
and this is what I planned in the game I
saw this position and looked a little
bit and I felt I should be better
because Bishop g7 rook H to d8 us on the
cards and he still has some problems
there I mean this is this is just
hanging and it's not so easy to ignore
still that's what he should have done
he played Knight b3 and now I cancelled
Queen side and put my knight on to see
form this is now really unbearable
another pressure is too high plate rupee
wanted to cover b2 and in this position
I calculated Knight xe3 but I wasn't
completely sure if I'm winning them and
it is winning and the engine quickly
confirms that yeah that this is a
winning attack but during the game
honestly I saw that Bishop g7 is also
very strong the only thing that I need
to do is to play d4 like completely
detonate the center and then White's
King position will be telling
yeah the whole problem that he has a CSO
dark-squared bishop and the all these
squares and pawns are weak so Bishop g7
is a bit of a lazy lazy move compared to
93 but it does win here simply no way of
preventing this breakthrough yeah now
after deform white is completely lost
and threatening far too much he played
the movie form and now a couple of
continuations win what I played is
enough Knight takes b2 somebody taking
this pawn after rook takes I grew up
here taking the Queen and attacking the
rook which will win huge chunks of
material so after night [ __ ] we had to
move the Queen and now I simply took and
him he resigned the game also being in
quite severe time trouble is also lost
to me regardless of the time I'm pawns
up and threatening c-4 check and it's
it's a complete disaster so we see that
this line with Bishop g4 is not bad
really
the let's say sane choices we should be
293 are not very scary and don't require
much of a theoretical workload to master
and f3 leads to somewhat murky unclear
play so if you are looking for a quick
easy weapon against the London this
could be one for you take note that
again we are talking about this
particular move water there's always you
know people starting with this and go
here or they can also after Bishop a
form and play this and then you have a
different line this is not a problem
it's just like it's not a universal
weapon that will work every time most of
the time however this is the way they
play because this gives white some more
flexibility in regards to certain lines
after
black plays something else in Bishop g4
this is why this movement is often
recommended in in books and and other
content that is released videos and so
on and I don't have the current theory
on the London London system on the white
side there are some things that have
been released DVDs and so on if you own
some of those I would be very interested
to learn what those DVDs recommend or
DVDs books whatever you have what they
recommend against Bishop g4 in some
cases I can imagine they don't even
cover the move all right I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching